a question I get asked all the time is
Lucca how can you memorize so many words
across so many languages and my simple
answer is I build a word spider web and
in this video I'm going to give you the
tools to create it to maintain it and to
make it stronger if I say this word game
what is the very first thing that comes
to your mind
probably something associated with
playing playing games but the reality is
that game has many other meanings for
example you can say I was hunting game
meaning I was hunting wild animals or
are you game like are you down do you
want to do something so this goes to
show that many words have multiple
meanings and functions according to
their context and what gives a meaning
context that is surrounding words so
whenever you find a word that you don't
know in a foreign language always make
sure that you either take the sentence
in which that word is embedded and you
copy it somewhere on your notebook for
example or you create your own sentence
in which you embed that word a very
common mistake is for example to take
all these words that you don't know from
a text and simply put it on a list but
isolated words are not as strong as
words in context embedded in sentences
always remember that as a first world
a simple yet very effective way to
memorize and learn new words is to
listen while reading think about it for
a second you can for example read a text
as a beginner material or you can have
podcasts with scripts or movies with
subtitles the most important thing is
you listen while reading or reading
while listening if you just listen to
the language without subtitles or a
script you will not see the written word
you will probably not understand if you
don't have a good level on the other
hand if you just read a text you will
not see and hear how the language is
spoken so you will miss out on the
spoken language easiest solution read
while listening as much as you can when
you read a text in a foreign language
there's a very high chance that you're
going to stumble upon a lot of words
that you don't know a very common
reaction is to try to strike and
underline and look up every single word
that appears on the text I don't think
that this is an efficient way to deal
with it a much more efficient ways to
focus just on the words that are
relevant for you let me give you an
example if you're an engineer words such
as tile or pillar will probably much
more interesting and relevant to you
than if you were a doctor for example
and for a doctor some other words might
be more interesting and anyway the brain
discards a lot of words that it deems is
not important so just focus on one third
of the unknown words that you find in
the text because the brain will remember
those words if they're relevant for you
heart elephant and sand if you think
about it these simple words have a
constellation of elements around them
for example you can say pink elephants
or the elephant in the room to draw a
line in the sand at the heart of the
matter
golden heart and so on and so forth this
goes to show that the brain creates big
networks of associated elements and this
is how you can use your brain in order
to start learning new words every new
piece of information you can link it to
old pieces of information so always make
sure that you look at words from this
perspective and thinking how can I
associate this new piece of information
to the other pieces of information in
the network that I have talked about and
this is the word spiderweb I was talking
about at the beginning of this video
[Music]
some languages have notoriously long
words let's take the German word flying
shafts bit Saigon which means display of
friendship but if you think about it the
first reaction is to get scared but the
length of this word but then when
looking closely you will realize that
this word is made of front shaft
friendship and bataya
orbits I'm gonna display displays off
this makes the word easier to retain
easier to pronounce and easier to
remember so get into the habit of
looking at words as made of smaller
parts if you learn how these smaller
parts make longer words things will get
much easier in terms of everything
[Music]
Romans used to say a repetitive end
which means repeating helps and that's
true and that's what we do a college
university at school we tend to repeat
things over and over but repeating
things in the very same way in which we
had been exposed to the very first time
is not actually a very efficient way of
dealing with texts let me give you a
metaphor imagine that you have to
conquer a castle that is conquering the
language if you always attack it through
the main door the defendants will
realize your tactics and your strategy
and it will be easier to defend the
castle if instead you attack the castle
from multiple angles you are more likely
to win the battle to give you a very
concrete example if you listen while
reading the text the very first time did
you get exposed to it three or four days
down the line do things differently
maybe just listen to the text or just
read it or listen to it in the target
language while reading it in your own
native language
whatever is different is irrelevant and
it makes a big difference in the way our
brain retains information because we're
adding variety to it novelty and
repetition is a fantastic combination to
retain words texts and whatever you want
[Music]
vadoma Volant said scriptum anand spoken
words fly while written words stay
another wise quote from the wise romans
why is this irrelevant 2,000 years ago
as it is now it's because words that are
spoken just fly around the air and you
need a system in place to catch them so
always make sure that you have a device
and note-taking device be it your mobile
phone or your notebook to catch these
words and these sentences on the fly you
can do it everywhere you can do it while
you're sitting and you're trying to
learn the language and you can do it
while you're talking to your friends in
a bar you can do it even while walking
and you come up with a word that you
want to know in the meaning of in a
foreign language whatever it is just
make sure that you have a notebook that
you can fit in your pocket
and you can carry it with you at all
times and another tip is when you mark
words or sentences always make sure that
you mark the place and the time where
this happened because it's going to give
you a very clear reference in time and
space for your episodic memory it makes
a huge difference if you get into the
habit of doing this every single day
this video contains a lot of information
and I've condensed it for the sake of
brevity and clarity if you want to know
more you can click on the link in the
description box below and you will be
able to read a very extensive article
about this very same topic so here you
have it these are the seven tools to
create and strengthen your word
spider-man all you need to do now is to
get out there and catch as many word
flies as possible
[Music]
you